hello students are you ready to be thrown into
a pool of the unknown you will be critiqued and
criticized in front of your peers you will work
long days and long nights endlessly many times
without knowing what you are looking for you
will have to do the same things over and over
and over again your project will haunt you from
the moment you wake up to the moment you sleep
if you're going to sleep that is if you're
ready for this then sit tight because in this
video i'm going to give you 10 life tips that
i wish i had when i was in architecture school
just over 10 years ago when i was just 18 years
old i decided to make the biggest investment of
my life and applied for architecture school
i spent about seventy thousand dollars and
six years of my life drawing sketching getting
criticized for my work and falling asleep
in the computer lab it's kind of crazy
when you think about it with any other
type of investment you would want some kind
of certainty in the success of the outcome
but when it comes to our education we kind of
go into it with blind faith don't get me wrong
i am very happy that i made that decision 10 years
ago and i can't imagine myself doing anything else
but recently i have been thinking about how i
could have maximized the returns on my investment
and how different life would be if i knew 10
years ago some of the things that i know now
so in this video i want to talk about 10 things
i wish i knew or thought about before starting
architecture school focus on building meta skills
as well as your hard skills so i remember this one
time i was working on a project with a classmate
and i was just really frustrated because i felt
like he was not really contributing on the
design and i just felt like he wasn't really
pulling his weight i'm sure you are also gonna
come across a situation like this because there
are a lot of group projects and everyone kind
of has different standards and everyone has
different ways of working you know and some
people are just not that great to work with
but when you leave school and work in an office
this is something that principals or project
architects have to do every day you know they need
to teach young interns they need to explain things
to clients and consultants and every day we're
solving problems that are not just design related
but people related so these kind of unfortunate
but inevitable group situations are kind of the
perfect opportunity for you to practice how
to communicate and also how to inspire people
and how to explain things and i think these are
all skills that are gonna become very helpful down
the road develop a skill that you can monetize
when i finished architecture school i had around
50 000 in student loans and my
starting intern salary was 50 000 so
my mindset was to do everything and anything
possible to pay this back as fast as possible
so i started looking at like looking for side
work like i knew how to draft i knew how to
do renders i knew how to take photographs so
i told all my co-workers and everyone i knew
that if they ever needed any of these things
i could do it for a really really good price
and so i started getting some work here and
there but what i didn't realize is that the
work would take way more time than i had
anticipated because i wasn't actually that
good at any of them compared to a professional
i also didn't know how to charge properly
to compensate for my time so it actually took me
um a couple tries to get to a level where i could
actually like offer my services
professionally for a decent fee if you are
someone who wants to offer some side services
check out places like upwork and fiverr and see
what level of competence is out there and how
much you can charge for them something else that i
learned is that you should try to get into
the habit of setting your own price and
asking what you think you're worth obviously
do the research but one of the things that i
realized makes a really big difference in
your fee surprisingly is not necessarily the
um the quality of the work but it's actually
the quality of the service so if you are
able to communicate with your clients really well
give them timely responses and feedback you'll
get great reviews and you can charge a lot more
this is especially prevalent now where you have
people charging like literally five dollars for
a rendering so i think the communication and
the service actually makes a really big difference
and i was actually pretty surprised about this too
there's just so many ways for you to make
money these days that's not tied to your
job and architecture school is a really great
place for you to explore some of those skills
but it's your job to make it specific and unique
enough for it to be marketable grades don't really
matter this might kind of come as a surprise but
unless you're applying for scholarships or awards
grades don't really matter in architecture school
as long as you pass everything i used to get so
mad about getting a b because um asian but uh
i realized after graduating that people just
really look at your portfolio and nobody really
cares like you gotta see instructors and maybe
this is kind of a contentious argument because
of course like you want to do your best work but
if i knew this in architecture school i feel like
i would have done a couple things differently
for example if it came down to sitting down
and like really understanding something versus
finishing an assignment on time but like really
fast for a deadline so you gather your friends and
you pull your resources i would have chosen to sit
down and like really understand the problem and
the solution even if it meant getting a lower
grade in the assignment you always think that
you're going to come back to it and go over
it later but you rarely do so if i actually
knew that starting out i think my strategy for
school would have been a little bit different
iterate and document the process design
is an iterative process so don't be one
of those people who falls in love with their
first idea really good designers are able to
iterate through different options and change
their design drastically really quickly your
design is going to change as you try different
options and you might circle around and come back
to your initial idea but because of this it's so
so so so important for you to document the process
sometimes it's not about the idea but the process
and how you got to that final point and i've also
mentioned this in my how to create an architecture
portfolio video that in fact the thought process
is what firms are more interested in seeing not
really beautiful renderings because beautiful
renderings are so common these days understand the
law of diminishing returns just because design is
an iterative process it doesn't mean that you
should work on your project without any time
constraints and i think the law of diminishing
returns is just as applicable in design
and if you don't know what it is it's an economic
theory that tells us that after a certain point
you will have reached an optimal level of capacity
and adding any additional inputs will actually
reduce the returns on the inputs so this over
here is you right in the morning or right after a
coffee break you're pumping out your drawings and
iterations and here maybe you go and have dinner
and it's starting to get late and it's 3am and
you can't remember what you've been working on for
the past hour your computer's starting to crash
and you're forgetting where you saved your file
i've been there and i remember it like yesterday
try to understand your peak times and when you're
the most effective i think everyone kind of has a
time when they're the most effective and everyone
also has the time when they're the most creative
when i was doing my masters i realized that i was
a better writer in the mornings and that i could
come up with more interesting design solutions
in the evenings so once i actually started
implementing this into my days and started
building a routine around it i was just
so much more effective and i was getting
so much more done and i was getting so much
more quality work done learn from your crits
i remember this one time i had a pretty pretty
bad crit and i was fairly upset about it not
just because i worked on this thing for days and
nights on end not just because my worth was so
intimately attached to this project not just
because the juries poked some really fair holes
into my project but because i was not really
able to answer a lot of the questions that
that they threw at me i was so upset that when the
crit was over all i wanted to do was just go home
shower and go to sleep i just really wanted to
erase the memory of that entire crit from my mind
when i woke up i made it a point to go through
the notes that my friend had taken for me
and look at the project objectively and this is
actually the project that eventually led to my
thesis project which i won the aia henry adams
award for i think crits are possibly the most
critical learning moments of your project
because you have your group of juries most of
whom have never seen your project before and
they're reacting purely to your presentation of it
and it's a fairly accurate assessment of your
design and your ability to communicate your ideas
and you will have bad crits that's for
sure and you'll also have good crits
what's really important is that you think of them
as an opportunity to get critical feedback on your
work and on your thought process and you you learn
from that and you will continue to have crits
after school and into your career so it's really
important for you to have a growth mindset about
this actively ask questions and engage your profs
so school is an environment and probably the few
phases of your life where you're gonna be
surrounded with people who have much much much
more knowledge than you and at the same time their
whole job is to teach you stuff don't be afraid
of asking dumb questions remember that saying he
who does not ask a question remains a fool forever
meaning you might look stupid asking that question
in class but if you don't ask it you'll never know
the answer when instead you can just try to get
over the fear of looking stupid in the moment
and honestly the chances are if you have that
question it's very likely that other people have
that question too learn how to communicate your
ideas clearly so what i've learned over the years
of working in the field is that the architects who
become principals and partners they have one thing
in common they are incredible communicators but
i feel like we're not really taught to do this
enough were kind of thrown into the deep end
which is also why some presentations can go
really badly even if they have amazing projects if
you're interested i actually have a few videos on
presentation techniques i'll leave it right here
as a general rule of thumb try to spend some time
before a deadline to think about how you are going
to present your ideas and please don't just wing
it build systems around your workflow and stay
organized so this might sound a little boring but
this is one of those things that's gonna save
you so much time and energy down the road
and if you've been doing this regularly for a
few years it's gonna it's gonna provide you with
a library of knowledge that you can access
anytime so there's certain processes that we do
very regularly like producing renderings
or laser cutting or taking notes
where a lot of the steps in the process
can be replicated so for example
when i'm doing a rendering i first try to identify
which materials are worth rendering and which
are better to do it in photoshop and my camera
settings preset for my exterior renders and i
have a preset for all my interior renders so that
i don't have to go in and like adjust the settings
every single time and in post-production i have
all my people and materials saved in a folder
and all the people are divided into different
folders based on what they're doing i always try
to save them in the same spot every single time i
think one of my biggest regrets in life is that i
didn't start taking proper notes at an earlier
age i would write things down in my notebook
and when i ran out of pages i would just get
a new notebook and eventually forget about the
thing that i learned and written down so now i
track everything all of the new information that
i learned into notion into separate categories
so that i can look it up later because if there's
one thing that life has taught me it is that you
should never trust your brain to store information
of course there are certain things that
cannot be turned into a system or are not
worth turning into a system but i think it's very
important to kind of always have this mindset
build good relationships you can't
get through architecture alone
that's a simple fact architecture is a social
profession you need to bounce ideas off each other
you need that person who's gonna tell you that
your idea is [ __ ] you need that person to go on
late night snack runs with you you need that
person that you can complain to about your profs
if you're working in studio you will naturally
kind of develop these relationships because studio
is kind of this like crazy magical environment
that's very hard to replicate anywhere else
so that's a part of what you're paying
for when you go to architecture school
there's all these people working on their own
project like drawing cutting gluing and putting
things together and taking them apart i can't even
recount how many times i've had like breakthrough
moments in the studio architecture is also a
very small community compared to other fields
that once you get into the workforce
a lot of people know each other
or is once removed your friends in school are
going to be the people that you're going to
enter the workforce with you so eventually they
are going to become your professional network and
you know there is no better way to tell if
somebody is going to be a good co-worker and then
like doing a project with them um or working
through those late nights and studios together
you'll you'll know exactly what that
person looks like when they're sleeping
you'll know what they smell like
when they have really bad meal
and you'll know all of
their poor eating habits yes
i still have friends from architecture school from
like 10 years ago that i would vouch for because
i know their work ethic and i know that they're
going to be a good fit at any firm so although in
this video i try to focus on maximizing
the returns on your investment in time
and energy the most important thing you will
actually get out of architecture school is not
really something you can buy with any amount of
money things like lifelong bonds and memories
and like appreciation for beauty and like a
life-changing experience that you won't be able
to get anywhere else it's not going to be easy
or fast but it's going to teach you perseverance
amazing work ethic it's going to teach you to
trust in your own abilities you learn to work
yeah you learn how to work work work yeah
hello darkness my friend
i've come to talk with you again if you
are just about to start architecture school
or maybe you're already a few years in um i'd love
to hear which of these things resonate with you
and if you are an old fart like me and you've
already graduated are there things that you
wish you thought about before you started
architecture school that you could share with
the rest of us let me know down in the comments
below i'm really curious to hear what you think
you